well knots of screaming progressives
increasingly a fact of life across the
country certainly here in Washington
leaders on the Left are causing this
they're egging on their followers and
from restaurants the steps of Supreme
Court the followers are responding it's
been going on for months now leaders the
Democratic Party has said virtually
nothing about it so of course it's
getting worse the headquarters of the
Manhattan Republican Party was just
vandalized in the Upper East Side after
a week of getting harassing phone calls
meanwhile the left continues to
projector is the right that is
fetishizing violence Howard Dean who
once ran for president despite
intellectual disabilities wrote this
quote Trump seems to like people who
murder their opposition bet he'd like to
do the same said Howard Dean former
governor dan bhajiya was a former Secret
Service officer an NRA television
contributor and he joins us tonight
dan this does seem like projection here
so the left gets more violent they
become more convinced that it's actually
the right getting violent yeah I don't
believe for a second and I don't want to
speak for you Tucker but I don't think
you do either that the left actually
believes the right right is violent and
the reason I say that is they've had to
fabricate stories to make the right
appear violent remember the famous
episode up on the hill during Obamacare
where a number of congressmen alleged
they were that racial slurs were hurled
at them and that they were spat on and
yet numbers and multiple people said
listen we'll give you a $10,000 if you
can produce a scintilla video evidence
that this actually happened and they
didn't you know we had the famous Sarah
Palin you know bullseye pictogram which
had been used repeatedly throughout
history and that was an indicator of a
so they're just making this up but Chuck
I see two real problems here number one
is the remember the left need state
power because they're takers they're
takers of your money your Liberty your
freedom your health care they need state
power to do that as they lose it this is
almost like an extinction burst of
behavior for them to use a psychological
term but secondly the real problem
Tucker that I know you've been
highlighting recently is the media on
the left their normalization of this
chaos is deeply disturbing and it's an
effort to cover for the Democrat Party
and that's what's troubling I totally
agree we have we just got the latest
afternoon video kind of an amazing
exchange so on capita hose you know it's
now very common for people to show up
and start screaming at lawmakers
Republicans Senator Bill Cassidy of
Louisiana walking down the hallway this
afternoon I think this afternoon and had
this exchange I want to put it up for
our viewers to see it
[Music]
lemon or Cassidy can you please
apologize to my children for ruining
their futures hey guess what if in the
future somebody makes it I know you're
here to use you as tools
I don't know Bill Cassidy but I'm
impressed by his calmness and clarity is
that the answer to screaming mobs
calmness clarity yeah it always this
because and listen Tucker I don't think
it's a big mystery like I I can get
feisty sometimes my Queens personality
comes out but there's a reason this
works when I ran for office in Maryland
I'll never forget this you're not
speaking to the liberal the liberal in
many of these cases is irrational Czerny
committed to the fact that you're an
evil person that not just that you have
evil ideas right what you're speaking to
is the third party listening and in this
case the social media ecosystem because
everything's on tape people who see that
are now gonna say wait
that lady cared so much about her
children why did she chase Bill Cassidy
down the hall then and leave them there
who brings their children up to Capitol
Hill to confront the United States
Senator I mean listen I'm all for big
our rights to free speech to protest but
I mean that seems kind of out rate what
are your kids know about the Supreme
Court policy or has a confirmation
process it's absurd and it's pure evil
to use your children as political props
and drag them into a political debate is
disgusting and I'm saying that as a
parent I'm free to make that judgment
it's I don't think any normal parent
would do that it's bizarre actually yeah
I wouldn't either Tucker right I mean I
don't need to talk politics with my
adult children like please thank you Dan